i had a question from
numerous safety 3796 and this was from a
long time ago i also was kind of putting
this off much like you were with the
last question i i just didn't want to
get into it because it's about
ashwagandha
and performance effects so the question
is basically what are my thoughts about
ashwagandha for physical performance and
it also specifically refers to
a meta-analysis now when i first got
this question i was like cool a
meta-analysis i love digging into those
uh if you're a mass subscriber like i
had a really
painful hobby for a while there of kind
of taking metas apart
finding some little calculation errors
and then putting them back together
um i say it was a painful hobby because
that takes so long
if there's more than like four studies
um so anyway i opened this up thinking
it'd be an opportunity because i know
the ashwagandha exercise literature is
not that big so i was like oh i can dig
into this and probably find some errors
and put it back together i think the
meta-analysis itself was done quite well
my concern is i just think the body of
literature is so scattered and
inconsistent
and i think the mechanisms are so vague
i truly don't know what to do with it
and usually when i'm there with a
supplement i say listen if you're really
intrigued and you want to give it a shot
there's enough safety data to suggest
that as long as it's not an adult rated
product and not just and and you're
following dosing guidelines like
if you want to take a crack at it take a
crack at it but i haven't seen enough
evidence despite the existence of this
meta-analysis to
really feel good about recommending
ashwagandha for performance purposes
if you look around at some of the
research that people often point at when
it comes to ashwagandha as a performance
booster there was one paper that i see
floating around every now and then that
you know
like
over the course of i think maybe eight
weeks or so uh you know it was kind of a
standard length for uh for a training
intervention it was like eight maybe ten
weeks or so
uh the ashwagandha group added 46
kilograms to their bench press
and so like yeah i don't know yeah it
was eight weeks so
maybe that happened maybe it didn't
but if it did happen
like a lot of kilos
my question is to whom does that really
generalize you know like yeah
ashwagandha is not going to add 46
kilograms to your bench press so i don't
know what to do with that particular
finding but that that's one that a lot
of people get
uh excited about and to be fair like
maybe they were just really really
really really untrained there was no
familiarization
and so it was just like hey over the
next eight weeks we are going to teach
you how to bench press and sprinkle in
some additional supplement magic and and
here we go but in any case there's
nothing that i can do with with that
right yeah so
there's also um
yeah if you look at the effect sizes
within this meta analysis
um
you would kind of be left to conclude
that ashwagandha is
more effective than creatine
by a pretty comfortable margin and i
find that to be implausible uh at this
point in time just because of
inconsistency from study to study and
and also like i mentioned uh the
the mechanism doesn't make a lot of
sense to me
um
some papers will will talk very vaguely
about ashwagandha's mechanisms and say
like well it's
you know you're doing these stressful
things and ashwagandha will make them
less stressful and all of a sudden
you're benching 46 more kilograms and
i'm like i got you got to get me closer
to how i got those 46 kilograms yeah i
mean if that is the relevant mechanism
just like dude you should see a similar
ergogenic effect from smoking weed right
but just doing a little something to
take the edge off in the evening but
yeah i mean i was looking at one paper
and it says it referred to this is a
quote anti-stress effects
neuroprotective effects immunomodulatory
effects and rejuvenating effects via the
herbs interplay with the nervous system
the endocrine system the cardiopulmonary
system energy production system and the
immune system including analgesic
antimicrobial anti-inflammatory
anti-tumor anti-stress anti-diabetic
neuroprotective immunoprotective and
cardioprotective effects good [ __ ] so
like
what am i supposed to do with that like
yeah it just does all things in all
contexts so
but when you when you start to dig into
it a little bit uh you basically will
find um
two primary like specific mechanisms one
is
cortisol reduction which i don't think
you could really say you know yeah
cortisol is leading to the effects we
see in that meta-analysis effects of
that magnitude man in
in addition to that there was a
there was a paper i think it came from
stu phillips's lab
maybe like 2013 2014 thereabouts um like
like back when the acute hormone
hypothesis for for training adaptations
was was kind of the hot topic and people
are doing research to see like you know
does does that seem to be like the
primary mechanism for muscular
adaptations
so they they had a paper where they were
looking at the correlations between um
between hormonal responses to training
and uh resistance training adaptations
it was either strength gains or
hypertrophy it was one of the two um
but if memory serves because i didn't
pull this this paper up before recording
if memory serves they looked at changes
in testosterone
cortisol
um
growth hormone igf-1 i think it was
those four and none of them were
associated with training adaptations
except for cortisol which was positively
associated with training adaptations
right so like you know i i wouldn't
necessarily want to take um
correlation data from a single paper at
face value but
i mean of the human data that i'm aware
of uh
a relatively large cortisol response
post training
probably either doesn't meaningfully
predict training adaptations or might be
positively predictive of training
adaptations so like if that's the main
mechanism you're hanging your hat on
like oh yeah this this reduces cortisol
i don't know i don't even know that
that's a good thing
right and you know there is a
distinction between you know kind of
basal resting cortisol throughout the
day versus the acute fluctuations from
training but yeah for sure again it's
yeah there's
minimal evidence to suggest that a
little reduction in cortisol whether
we're talking about
during exercise post exercise or
throughout the day is going to have
dramatic effects on body composition
performance
so and then sometimes people say well no
it's it's affecting the hpa or the hpg
axis but it's more affecting
testosterone it's increasing
testosterone and ashwagandha is not
increasing your testosterone enough to
have those types of ergogenic effects
you need a big change in testosterone to
have a significant ergogenic effect on
that magnitude has anyone checked to see
the ectisterone content of uh
of ashwagandha that's a good question
another mechanism that does come up is
sometimes they say listen it's got
antioxidant properties and that's good
but i wrote an
article for stronger by science about
antioxidants there are many of them they
do antioxidant things quite well and
they do not have these types of
performance outcomes so
maybe to be fair maybe ashwagandha is
remarkably efficacious as an ergogenic
aid and we simply have no idea what the
mechanism is um but to me that's that's
not enough to get me really to latch
onto a supplement and recommend it i
need to see
you know consistent plausible effect
sizes that make sense based on a
mechanism that has been supported by
some experimental research
and right now there's just really a
disconnect where the effect sizes are
really big there are very few of them uh
they are a bit inconsistent from study
to study
i can't really point to a mechanism that
would tie it all together so when it
comes to ashwagandha for performance i'm
personally going to sit this out
i've taken ashwagandha before for an
extended period of time because
there is some amount of evidence
suggesting that it might help with
attenuating symptoms of like very mild
anxiety um
so i've taken it for that um whether or
not i experienced a placebo effect from
it i don't really know uh it didn't like
change my life but it seemed fine
um but i certainly didn't notice
pronounced ergogenic effects when i was
taking ashwagandha for for that type of
outcome
so um
you know if you're super intrigued by it
by all means you know you can give it a
shot just make sure you're not getting
an adult rated product make sure you're
taking it within
recommended dosage guidelines you can
take a shot on it if you'd like but
personally i don't see strong evidence
supporting
a an ergogenic effect with plausible
consistent effect sizes with a mechanism
that would explain how it would be doing
that type of thing but i do want to say
i want to acknowledge that you know this
does kind of fall under that ayurvedic
medicine umbrella there are some
traditions and cultures in which
ashwagandha is held in really high
regard and so i don't mean to be
disrespectful to any of those
traditional elements or cultural
elements
if you really like using ashwagandha for
reasons
that are based on you know culture
tradition whatever the case may be i'm
not trying to be a dick and you know
insult that or take away from that or
anything but when people have these
questions for us about supplements it's
usually through the prism of kind of
uh by the book evidence-based medicine
or evidence-based practice do you see
enough evidence
empirically to support this i'm not
seeing the experimental evidence
that i would need to justify promoting
it as an ergogenic aid yeah and i i just
want to add one thing to head off a
maybe like a potential criticism of the
the answer you just gave um so you know
one of the things you said is like
you'll
you might would have more faith in it if
there was more high quality human
research on it one one thing that i
know that
that some people's brains will go to
it's like well
well man like there's a reason that
there's not that much research on it
like it's an herb you can't patent it uh
there's no there's no profit motive so
like people
people aren't going to
um
you know pour the same sort of money
into research because there's no way
that you can like monetize this the same
way you could other things like that
that's a common like anti-pharma talking
point um but in the case of supplement
research like
that that just doesn't pass the smell
test for reality because like a lot of
the most studied supplements out there
is [ __ ] that can't be patented because
it's naturally occurring so like
creatine for example or caffeine
or fish oil i think those are the three
like like one two and three the most
studied supplements in existence and
they're they're all stuff that uh
exists in nature that you can't patent
like you can you can package and sell it
but you know it's the same sort of thing
as an herbal extract um
so yeah i i know that some people
some people's brains will go there as
kind of an explanation for why there's
not more high quality human data on it
but
in the case of supplementation that
that critique just doesn't hold water
yeah and and like i said uh some of
these findings they're just
the effect sizes just seem too big to me
and i know that
uh you know when people hear that the
first thing they think is just like
straight up fraud that's not what i'm
suggesting but like
a lot of times with studies the first
few papers that trickle out for any
particular
supplement or treatment whatever the
case may be
a lot of times we see really inflated
effect sizes and we see effect sizes
that are not generalizable that are not
representative of the true effect size
and only after we get a ton of different
studies do we start to see oh
the early phase of research for this
ingredient we saw a lot of publication
bias and we saw a lot of inflated effect
sizes that were not necessarily due to
fraud or anything like that but they
were just sampling error and kind of the
like first finders effect where where
the first time you do it uh you you know
there could be several very
uninteresting ashwagandha studies that
are just kind of sitting in cupboards
you know in the file drawer and uh you
know it's only when you
happen to get this kind of
non-generalizable but flashy finding do
you say oh this is something that could
really make a splash so
anyway yeah i'm not that into it as an
ergogenic aid but if you're into it hey
more power to you